one of our next presenters is the next
category is David Elwell / as you know
David was the producer of the hugely
successful television movie roots David
has a new series coming up called
celebrity roots and in the first episode
Sammy Davis jr. tracks his roots back to
his great-great-great grandfather Kunta
Davis senior and he finds that even
though Kunta was a slave he wore fewer
chains than Sammy does in his act today
where David is a lovely an actress with
impressive credentials would you welcome
please Mia Farrow
and David Wolper
leads here the Academy honors
documentary films in two categories
let's begin with the short subjects
David the nominees for documentary Short
subject are the divided trail a Native
American Odyssey Jerry Aronson producer
an encounter with faces KK capital
producing the flight of the gossamer
Condor Jacqueline Philip shed and been
shed producers always chicken Khurana
producer Squires of San Quentin J Gary
Marshall producer and the winner is the
flight of the gossamer Condor Jacqueline
Philip said and then said producers
I'd like to thank the members of the
Academy for this great honor during the
past two years it often seemed like
finishing this film was an impossible
dream as was man-powered flight but
McCrady made it and so did we I'd like
to express our deepest gratitude to all
those who gave us their support during
this time and especially to mr. Robert
Churchill Simon Campbell Jones in London
and Boyd Estes our cinematographer we
couldn't have done it without you
I want to thank Harry and Florence
Phillips Robert and Beverly shed all
that creative people who worked on the
production we share this honor with you
special thanks to my fellow filmmakers
George McQuillan Oscar Williams and
Eleanor Bingham special thanks to my
friends got me through this thing and to
my special assistant my daughter Nara
this time I took to make this film to
dr. Paul MacCready who invented and
built the gossamer Condor and proved
that man really can fly Thank You
members of the Academy
next the nominees for outstanding
documentary feature film are the lovers
wind al Birla Maurice producer
mysterious castles of clay Allen root
producer Ronnie jean-pierre Dooley ter
Barry Williams and Mikel gas produces
scared-straight honest epillow
producing
with babies and banners story of the
women's emergency brigade Anne Boleyn
Lynne Goldfarb Lorraine gray produces
and the winner is scared straight
well I thank all the members of the
Academy who voted for scared-straight as
a matter of fact I'm so happy I thank
all of you who didn't vote for it the
lifers of Rahway prison in new jersey
who are watching this telecast deserve
really all the credit there wouldn't
have been a film without the fine work
that they are doing in an attempt and I
might add an effective attempt to divert
juveniles from pursuing a life of crime
I shared this with those men
also to a brilliant film editor bob
nieman
a brilliant cinematographer bill Moffat
a wonderful host Peter Falk and my staff
of course at Golden West broadcasting
the most creative and I might say
courageous group of television
management people who would take this
film with language that had never before
been on television and put it on first
in Los Angeles and then nationally mr.
Gene Autry John T Reynolds Luis Nogales
Tony Kucera
and Greg Nathanson and to the signal
companies for sponsoring it without
commercial interruption this is the
proudest moment of my life I share this
with all the people I mentioned but I'll
keep it thank you